the interesting span of topics and talks
in real-time decision-making I'm going
to talk about hybrid systems and really
maybe from an application driven point
of view methods that we've been
developing for decision-making in hybrid
systems based on both safety and
performance and I've been working for
years on different kinds of safety
critical systems and I think it's really
those applications that have kind of
pushed me into this direction of safe
decision-making so the application that
I've probably spent the most time on and
about 20 years now is on air traffic
systems this is a snapshot of traffic
air traffic across the Northern
California it's called the Oakland
Center so it's a region of airspace it's
controlled by a group of controllers
they're now situated in Sacramento so
there's a building the controllers get
radar information over you know of
aircraft that are flying over their
sectors of airspace and each sector of
airspace here kind of outlined in these
pink regions has a single controller and
the the goal of the controller is to
make sure that the number of aircraft in
that sector over any given period you
know they they stay safe they they go
from their origin in the sector to the
destination in their sector and they
don't come into a certain collision
distance with each other
and and for that reason the system is
organized so that the sector of airspace
typically has no more than about 15 or
18 aircraft at any given time and so you
can see in this in this picture the high
level cross traffic going through and
also the traffic that's actually coming
in and merging in this case it's into
San Francisco Airport okay so it's a
safety critical system in fact the
separation distances are now probably
it's sort of historical but with better
radar equipment those separation
distances are now going down but there's
still five nautical mile lateral
dural separation between aircraft and a
thousand-foot vertical separation
required outside of when you get close
into San Fran close to San Francisco
they have much better radars and of
course the aircraft can come closer
together but if you're in regions a
little bit further away from the airport
those are the current separation
distances so you can imagine these
virtual hockey pucks around each
aircraft and the hockey pucks can't
intersect each other so I think maybe
because it's such a safety critical
system and maybe historically the way
the system has been designed really
starting after the Second World War in
the Northeast Corridor and kind of
developing across the United States and
and I think because it's a very much a
human centered system both in the
context of air traffic controllers on
the ground and pilots in the air the
system has developed with these standard
routes so standard corridors of well
traveled routes and these are actually
you know aircraft they're the traces of
aircraft but they're following jet ways
between navigation equipment so between
these omnidirectional range radars and
if you zoom in on some of these
interesting intersections so aircraft
coming in for example and merging into a
route that's going to come in to San
Francisco and you watch how controllers
tend to manage this traffic they tend to
group traffic together a group aircraft
together by potential conflict so the
first thing they try to do is line up
aircraft along routes traveling all at
the same speeds so they can basically
turn that group of aircraft into one
aircraft because it's cognitively easier
to manage that group of aircraft and
they spend most of their time resolving
conflicts and situations like this where
you have aircraft that if they don't do
anything like slow an aircraft down or
speed an aircraft up or put it in a
detour then the aircraft will lose
separation with each other
so there's kind of a constant monitoring
of these intersection points and then
kind of looking ahead and seeing what it
what's the next critical situation that
can occur so controllers 10
two air traffic controllers tend to
control aircraft according to a kind of
hybrid model of I would say this is a
hybrid model of an aircraft under air
traffic control they tend to keep
aircraft for the most part in the speed
on the route the on the route that the
aircraft wants to fly at the speed
that's optimal for the altitude that the
aircraft is flying at and then there's a
small set of control actions that
they'll tend to apply so if they can
speed it if they can speed it up or slow
it down by about 10% of that optimal
velocity they'll do it if they speed it
up or slow it down by more than that
then it's not really optimal flight for
that density of aircraft at that
altitude and so to slow it down even
more they'll put them into detour or to
speed it up or slow it down they'll put
them into detours so so for example they
might just sort of cut the corner here
for one of the aircraft or do a short
cut in the sort of worst case result
they'll put them into a holding pattern
and you typically see these holding
patterns applied outside the the busy
like the the region around the urban
airports that's typically if you've been
in holding patterns where you've been
it's like circling over Marin outside
the San Francisco TRACON is something
that a lot of us have spent a lot of
time doing okay so so it's a very
interesting system I've worked on it for
a long time it's a very slow-moving
system you can imagine slow moving in
the sense of adopting new technologies
things have to be tested for a long time
before they're allowed into this system
but over the past five years there's
been quite a bit of excitement because
of unmanned air vehicles and the FAA has
been trying to understand how to adapt
the current air traffic management
system to allow for these new operations
that a lot of businesses and a lot of
people just you know they want to fly
their drones around and in particular
you know large large and sort of
influential businesses have been putting
pressure on the FAA to think about how
to make it easier to fly a UAV through
the National Airspace System of course
they're flying at much lower altitudes
but you know aircraft do land and take
off and it's real
important that there's no conflicts with
UAVs in those areas so now it's kind of
a clean slate and it really is I mean
it's interesting with NASA and looking
at the you know the projects that they
want people to work on it's like we want
to knew what they call UTM unmanned air
system traffic management system so UTM
instead of atm
which is our usual air traffic
management system and we'd like to
understand how to design it and so in
thinking about this you know in thinking
about adopting some of the principles
from the air traffic system namely what
they've done for safety what they've
done for simplicity when it's a human
centered system it's it's clear that
some of that will be adopted into the
new system so for example perhaps a root
structure that is flexible but it's
still you know well organized so if a
human has to intervene it's well
understood what these groups of vehicles
are doing perhaps some kind of control
structure onboard the aircraft or some
kind of understandable structure that if
a human has to intervene the you know
they know what the vehicle is doing but
these vehicles are autonomous and so
having the vehicle be kind of smart in
the sense that it should be able to
adapt to new information for example one
of the systems we're working on with
NASA is a forced landing system they
want to be able to force the vehicle to
land if there's any problem and they're
you know there there's nobody in the
vehicle but the damage can be done to
the surrounding environment so
understanding based on a fault that the
vehicle has what the best place for that
vehicle to land and given you know the
current sense of the geography is a very
important problem okay so I'm going to
present the some of the tools that we've
been developing in the context of this
problem and I've got really two points
to make one is about real-time
computation so we're talking about
real-time decision-making and some of
the tools we've been developing or you
know they they they really you know they
adhere to this curse of dimensionality
so what we've been doing in real-time
computation for that and then the the
kind of learn
Component how we bring in the ability to
adapt to new information yet still
maintain the proof of safety is is what
we've been really been interested in so
those those will be the two topics that
I'll focus on for the rest of the talk
we've been using the framework of hybrid
systems this is hybrid because it's
combining two different kinds of
modeling or two different kinds of
models finite state machine models or
discrete state models which are
represented here by this automaton and
then continuous state models represented
here by in this case I've used a
differential equation inside each
discrete state so the sentence is that
the system may have many different modes
of operation but in each mode of
operation there's a dynamic which
there's a model which is describing the
the physical evolution of the dynamics
and so you know in terms of that
aircraft the the aircraft under air
traffic control that we talked about
there's you know different modes
depending on the control mode that the
controller is using whether it's going
into a vector for spacing or a detour
but if you simplify the system that way
than the continuous dynamics in each
mode are very simple they're just linear
dynamics so that gives you a piecewise
linear system and that's easy to analyze
if you're looking at groups of aircraft
where this represents the the
composition of many different aircraft
now you know the state would represent
the composed state of a discrete state
couldn't mode of each of the aircraft
what what collision avoidance mode
they're in and then the continuous
dynamics would represent the joint
continuous dynamics of the aircraft that
you're looking at okay so here are the
two parts for the computation part I'm
going to talk about or really the the
safety control the first part I'm going
to talk about a tool we've been working
on for years now developing reachable
sets for hybrid systems I'll give an
overview and then I'll talk about some
examples and then for the second part
I'll end the talk by presenting it's
really our most recent work in
incorporating machine learning into
these reachable sets and how and what
kinds of guarantees of safety you can
make when you're doing machine learning
which is of interest to us because
we'd like this kind of high performance
we'd like to design adaptive systems
where we use data that's being collected
but we'd like to be able to in as much
as we can maintain proofs of safety so a
backwards reachable said it it's quite
an intuitive structure suppose that
suppose that you could and I'm just
plotting it here for some dynamic it
could be continuous we'll show it could
be hybrid but suppose you have some
continuous dynamics X is your state
space you have a control input a
disturbance input you can manipulate the
control you can't manipulate the
disturbance but suppose you know bounds
on the disturbance and so that dynamic
is causing a system to evolve suppose
that you could characterize in this case
let's call it unsafe T so you could
characterize unsafe States as some
subset of the system state space and
that's what this red ellipse here I've
called it G at time 0 this this set is
meant to represent it's the set of
states that you don't want the system to
get into well suppose you could compute
the backwards reachable set from that
set of states so that set is the the set
of states the set of configurations of
the system for which under these
dynamics the flow of the system could
enter that unsafe region and because
there's you know it could because
there's possibility to control the
system in a way that keeps it out of
that set but then you have to do that
counter to whatever disturbances could
be applied to the system usually in air
traffic those disturbances are not
trying to drive you to on safety but
there are disturbances you don't know
what they're going to do so you want to
be able to for a proof of safety you
want to be able to prove it for the
worst possible disturbance okay so this
backwards reachable set is the set of
all states for which for all possible
control actions there is a disturbance
which under the dynamics of the system
could drive the state in at most T time
units to that unsafe region so that's a
definition and and and the the idea of
control and disturbance so pitting
control against disturbance leads us to
this idea of
of use of describing it using game
theory that we're we're thinking about
you know the best possible control for
the worst possible disturbance so just
to so T is time so suppose you you know
the so we're going to we're going to
solve that differential equation for
certain time horizons and so really this
this little T here represents you know
one of those time horizons and that's
practical too because you know you're
usually solving collisions for the next
two minutes or something you've got some
time prize and after that it may be too
uncertain to be able to predict so just
to illustrate the point and I don't
really think I have to do this for this
audience but it's a nice little exercise
to do before lunch the point is uh is
well illustrated through this discrete
game that's there's ten states so not no
continuous dynamics it's just discrete
there's ten states Q 1 up to Q 10 and
there's two players player 1 will call
that the control the good guy and player
2 the disturbance or the bad guy and
then each player has two plays and the
plays are either 1 or 2 so each arrow
here representing transition from one
state to another has an ordered pair
representing the action of player 1 the
control which plays first and the action
of player 2 the disturbance so the
control plays first because we want to
be conservative with respect to the
control so the disturbance has the
advantage of seeing what the control has
just played at every instant in time and
then the arrows represent the
transitions and then these little stars
represent the wild card it means for
either either play one or play two so
let's label our unsafe set so G at time
0 is I'll just label it as Q 9 + Q 10 so
that's an assumption I'm assuming in all
of this that I can represent my
specification as a subset of the state
space of the system in this case safety
or unsafe T and so the idea is
and I you know it's it's dynamic
programming you you look at the boundary
of the unsafe set and you first ask
which states for which states on the
boundary meaning in this case in one
transition so one transition away is
there do they have the property that for
all possible control actions there's a
disturbance that could push the system
into the unsafe set and so we first look
at the states on the boundary so that
means the states for which there is one
transition so q4 is on the boundary q5
is on the boundary
q8 is on the boundary and so if you say
okay what's the in in one step what's
the backwards reachable set from q9 and
q10 you can just look at that and okay
well let's let's do it what is q5 in the
unsafe said so does it have the property
that for all possible control actions a
disturbance could push it into Q 9 and Q
10 and in one step it does right because
if if the control plays one you know you
could go to Q nine and if the control
plays to you could go to Q 10 you can
see this is a non-deterministic system
just from the the way it's described so
in one step Q five should be you know
encompassed in the reachable set what
about Q for the control and remember the
control can play the the control gets to
play first so if you were in Q 4 and you
were the control what would you do you
play one but play playing 1 it keeps you
in Q 5 takes you to Q 5 Q 5 is still not
in the reachable set at that iteration
or it could take you to Q 1 so so if you
if you step back one step the reachable
set includes Q 5 + QA 2 so we call that
G minus 1 because we're going backwards
in time and then you can continue now
you label your new unsafe set as the as
these four states and you just repeat
that process and so you find with this
simple example that after two steps you
reach a fix point namely if if you're in
Q 1 Q 2 Q 3 or Q 7 there's always a
control policy that can keep you outside
of that reachable set forever but but
that's not true for the state's labeled
in red
so that's the simple idea and so we we
worked on this for continuous systems so
in here the the solution so to be able
to solve it for that continuous dynamics
it turns out that if you characterize
the set say the unsafe set as the sub
level sets of a function so I'll use
this function J to represent the value
in the game and so J is less than zero
inside the unsafe set and greater than
zero outside then the the reachable set
becomes the Sub Zero level sets of this
function J as it propagates over time
where the propagation is governed by its
a it's a modified hamilton-jacobi
Isaac's PDE and there's some intuition
here you you if you look sort of take
our boundary argument again so we this
the left-hand side of the PDE describes
the evolution of this function over time
and on the right hand side I have within
this min with zero operation a max over
u min over D so the best possible
control for the worst disturbance of the
inner product of D J DX that's just the
outward pointing normal so at any X at
time T that represents the outward
pointing normal from the set the inner
product of that with the dynamics the
dynamics using that best control for the
worst disturbance so if the dynamics are
such that at that state for the best
control for the worst disturbance its
pushing you into that set that state
should be labeled as unsafe because you
know whatever you do you're going to be
pushed into the unsafe set and so that
means that that inner product that angle
is obtuse that becomes negative the min
with zero that makes it negative which
means J propagates J becomes negative at
that point and at the next step it's
included in the unsafe set so there's
there's some intuition you know if we
kind of look at the infinitesimal view
of this PDE
okay so suppose we could compute this
then we could theoretically compute the
reachable set and so in my group we
spent a lot of time computing these sets
for real systems and we've been using
this level set interpretation
so we use as I said a functional
representation of sets meaning that the
sets that we start with so this would be
J of X at time zero and then we're
solving as we solve for J of XT what
we're doing is we're capturing the Sub
Zero level sets of the evolution of that
function so this is meant to represent
kind of a slice of jxt at a particular
time horizon T
okay and there's a few points to make
here which come back when we talk about
learning that it turns out that if that
set is actually controlled invariant so
after a certain amount of time it stops
growing that means that if you stay
outside that set you're guaranteed
safety for all time so if it's
controlled invariant for all T then any
super zero level set of that of that set
is also invariant and can be used for
safety so that makes sense you can use
an over approximation of that cetera a
super zero level set of that of that set
for safety that's important and then
also if you optimize if you know a lot
about your disturbance functions so you
know you have a good model of your
disturbance then you that set becomes
less conservative it becomes smaller in
the sense of safety okay so in
particular if the disturbance were known
then one could theoretically compute the
optimal reachable set the smallest one
and then that's really just you know
that there's no disturbance acting but
the this is just based on the dynamics
of the system your dynamics you can't
turn away from that unsafe set fast
enough so it effectively partitions the
state space into what is either safe or
could become unsafe and you can't prove
that it can't become unsafe what's safe
and then the boundary and on the
boundary the technique gives you the
best control law to apply so that you
stay on the boundary or you're pushed
back into safety okay so we use these
some these level set functions you know
this is just an example it one of my
first PhD students he's now a professor
in CS at UBC coded this up into a level
set toolbox and it's available from his
website with a bunch of examples he came
he was a PhD student I was a professor
at Stanford before so he graduated from
Stanford and then he came to a postdoc
working with Praveen and in looking at
these ideas and robot planning ok so
here's an example here's for quadrotors
this was actually we did this when I was
back at Stanford so we call and we stay
even though we've moved to Berkeley we
still call this the star Mac test bed
because bar Mac doesn't sound as good as
star Mac so the Stanford testbed of
autonomous
craft this was before you could buy a
quadrotor on every street corner so we
built well if you see them up close we
built our own I was kind of proud of
those they're in our lab kind of a
museum but there are four quadrotors and
there are four students and so here you
see the data being played back around
each quadrotor you see three sets that
are growing and changing as the relative
configurations of the vehicles change
and in regular flight when they're not
touching each other's reachable sets the
students are controlling them through
joystick and the students are actually
trying to get them to collide and what
we've what what the algorithm is that's
programmed into these quad rotors is
this collision avoidance using reachable
sets so as soon as one of the vehicles
comes on the boundary of the reachable
set of another the automation will take
over and we'll guide the aircraft away
from each other
okay so it's an awful human-computer
interface example it's more like a
demonstration of how you might use how
you might apply this collision avoidance
in real time all right now these these
systems I'll talk a little bit about
this but they we can decompose the
dynamics and so we can actually solve
that hamilton-jacobi bellman equation in
real time which you can't do in general
so that that's sort of the important
thing for this workshop ok and and again
you can turn this problem around suppose
you have a desired set of states you'd
like to capture the problem becomes
really the same thing now it's instead
of a max over u min over D it's a min
over u Max over D and so here's the set
of states what for which you can
guarantee that the system will reach the
desired set despite the worst possible
disturbance that could be pushing it
away from the desired set and when I say
guarantee here it's in the sense that
guarantee if we trust the models that
we're using of the system so in the
sense of model checking
okay and then to the point of hybrid
systems you can sequence these
operations so suppose you have a target
set that you'd like to reach you could
compute the the backwards reachable set
of that target set and then your your
switching modes so you can compute from
some subset of that backwards reachable
set you could compute another backwards
reachable set and basically compute kind
of the back chain of operations that you
would need to apply to get to this
target set and you can combine that with
avoiding unsafe sets so we have this in
this toolbox that I talked about we have
this operator called a reach avoid
operator the set of states which can
reach a desired set while avoiding
unsafe sets and and the operation
because you're using level set functions
it's basically masking you can use these
operations of unions and intersections
of sets we solved them numerically so we
talked a little bit about that but we
use well we use level set methods to
solve for these sets and if you don't do
any kind of logical decomposition of
sets you can solve you know you're just
using a laptop computer you can solve
for three continuous state dimensions in
real time when I say real time I mean
like for the processors of these
aircraft okay so there's a community of
people working in reach ability a lot of
people are coming from the control
community and and and as you can imagine
the biggest problem in computing these
sets is dealing with you know the
computation and the representation of
these sets well this the the the storage
of these sets in in higher dimensions so
three states is not enough to represent
a group of aircraft because you want the
composition of the all aircraft in that
group so the state becomes big as you
include more aircraft and so leave over
the the different that I mean there's
there's a community of people working on
it and I've sort of divided these these
issues of dealing with the curse of
dimensionality so the methods people are
using into these four different arenas
so you can impose practical constraints
on the problem which i think is what
like 99% of people working on practical
problems do you actually even in air
traffic
you know you don't solve the
collision-avoidance problem for all 12
aircraft in your sector you group it
down to really those two or three
aircraft that are coming down that are
going to intersect at the intersections
a lot of work on approximations a lot of
work on looking at the mathematical
structure of the system and also
decomposition so let me talk about a few
of these one problem which is really
relevant for UTM as I defined it is
imposing practical constraints on the
problem so let's start with that okay so
this is example two I call it platooning
UAVs platooning comes from Praveen back
when I was a graduate student he was
working on the automated highway system
and proposing the use of platoons of
cars on the inner Lane of California's
highways and now even a traffic lights
as we saw in his talk the other day so
here this is just an example where so
you know suppose you have your Amazon
warehouse in Concord and these are
sending out you know you want your
iPhone in the next 30 minutes so you're
gonna call you're gonna pay the premium
to get your iPhone and so these
quadrotors or whatever amazon is using
are gonna fly to you know locations in
the Bay Area well if you put a cost map
so this comes to this back to this
forced landing system so water is cheap
because if it lands in the water it's
not a big deal the highly populated city
areas are expensive airports are really
expensive or regions around airports um
you know the parks and the forested
areas are relatively cheap but not as
cheap as water so given that cost map
you can solve and this is just you know
fast marching method for the shortest
path between that warehouse and main
drop-off points in the Bay Area and you
see the emergence of though all we did
was we solved fast marching and you see
the emergence of these trunk routes so
these kinds of highways in the sky that
exist already in the ATM system so you
know
well populate or well-traveled highways
and then short deviations into the
expensive regions which is what you
would expect
so with that we went ahead and thought
about a hybrid model for a UAV under
this in this kind of platoon or in this
kind of highway structure and we thought
about the idea of using platoons of UAVs
so UAVs flying at the same speed along
these highway routes and then you know
deviating or they're coming into a
highway merging into a platoon and then
deviating off when they needed to drop
off their package or perform whatever
operation they're performing bridge
inspection etc and so this is a
simplified version of it but basically
if the vehicle is not on a highway it's
free if it if it joins a highway it can
either join a platoon or be the leader
of a platoon so if it's on its own it's
the leader of its own platoon and then
these put these highways are at altitude
so if there's a vehicle that's faulty
you can use altitude as your as your
safety net so get it to descend and out
of the arena of the traffic so these
transitions you know leaving highway or
this is kind of a self-loop creating a
new platoon joining a platoon those
transitions are important and those we
want to compute we want no we don't want
to prescribe those we want the actual
guards for those transitions to come out
of the reach ability computations for
both reaching desired targets reaching
points on the highway within a platoon
as well as avoiding collision with other
UAVs around and so we used reachability
analysis to do that here's I'm going to
illustrate it through examples but
here's two vehicles a red vehicle and a
blue vehicle this is the highway this is
the desired point that the that the red
vehicle is once to join on the highway
and become its own platoon and this
represents its target set so once it
gets into this set here there's a
control law which will snap it onto the
highway or it's you know we define that
control law ahead of time so there's
some we basically you know use standard
control laws once it becomes so close to
the highway that it becomes a simple
control problem at the same time there's
another vehicle in the vicinity the blue
vehicle that it wants to avoid so this
red set represents the unsafe set of the
of the red vehicle with respect to the
blue view
that means that the red vehicle
shouldn't enter this red set given the
relative dynamics of those two vehicles
or they could come into collision so
it's basically what we talked about
before and so you can see you know the
progression it gets into its targets the
blue vehicles coming in now the bottom
row represents the action of the blue
vehicle also wanting to come in and join
the highway it's going to form a it's
going to follow the platoon created by
this red vehicle and so now it wants to
get into this blue region while avoiding
this dashed blue region so this
represents the reach avoid set for the
blue vehicle and and so if you do this
with all of the vehicles it
automatically computes the control
strategies to get these platoons to form
so we're not plotting the sets here
because it comes messy you have to
compute the sets of each vehicle with
respect to the other vehicles in the
vicinity but you see this kind of
organic formation of these platoons so
once they're in the platoon the vehicles
really only have to care about the
vehicle in front of it and the vehicle
behind it so this is where we're
imposing practical constraints on the
problem you don't have every vehicle
worrying about every other vehicle it
just turns it into you know a vehicle in
front and a vehicle behind and and you
can also account for things like
intruders so there's a vehicle that
doesn't follow any of the rules and it
just flies straight through as soon as
these vehicles are you know they're
touched by the reachable set the unsafe
set of the red vehicle they break from
the highway they break from the platoon
and then they join again once that
danger is over so those are those are
like basically automatic computations of
the guards of that of that highway the
platooning vehicle ok other methods for
dealing with the curse of dimensionality
we talked about imposing practical
constraints like you know roads highways
or protocols approximation so we've been
working recently on something which we
call decoupling disturbances and it
really comes into you know the dynamics
of the the differential equations here
so if you have the situation and I'm
just going
show a picture here where this is a this
is a reachable set for a four
dimensional vehicle XY position velocity
and the relative the heading of the
vehicle you can you can look at the
structure of the differential equation
and you can break it down into
subsystems using where each subsystem
can essentially be treated as an
independent system for reach ability
constraints that's nice because it
reduces the dimension of those
individual problems yet there's
typically coupling I mean it started
from one set of differential equations
any coupling variables we consider as
disturbances with respect to both
systems and so and and you can you can
look at the degree of the way you model
the disturbances and as you model the
disturbances with more and more fidelity
you get better and better approximations
as shown by these gray regions which are
over approximations to the actual
reachable set which are shown in green
okay but it turns a four-dimensional
computation into two two-dimensional
computations which seems you know that
that's good in theory but where it
becomes really useful and let me just
sort of skip ahead to some examples I
don't think I'm going to go through all
the details of the decoupling but you
know it comes into a handy so suppose we
have a six dimensional system using
these ideas of decoupling we can turn
that into two two-dimensional systems or
more interestingly something that we've
been working on for some of the
demonstrations you'll see at the end of
the talk here we have a 10 dimensional
model of a quadrotor in call it near
hover conditions by doing this kind of
decomposition we've actually created two
three-dimensional subsystems and one
one-dimensional subsystem so these
become very easy real-time computations
that can be done and then you use that
so basically you're computing the reach
ability operations in each of the
subsystems and then creating the exact
in this case reachable set for the 10d
system so this is very current work we
have a paper in this years well we had a
paper in last year's CDC and we've
submitted the
latest work to the the current CDC okay
question
that's a really good question so the
question is the is there a geometric
interpretation of the way we can think
about this I think so so what we have a
condition we know under what conditions
we can apply this it has to do with if
you have a coupling variable like a
control input that couples between two
subsystems and if the if the the action
that you need from that control variable
for one subsystem is conflicting with
the action that you need for the from
that control variable with the other one
then this isn't going to work so what we
want to what we're doing is
characterizing and we haven't got a
complete characterization but for which
for what systems that actually doesn't
occur so that you can use this
decoupling and there are some
interesting systems that we use in the
lab and I mean these quadrotor systems
we can show that that works but a
general result we don't have yet so this
is something that we're working on and I
think you know it definitely has to do
with it's the differential geometry of
the system okay so so now that's going
to the second part of the talk which
I'll really conclude on so I'll just
show some examples really where we're
trying to take these ideas of reachable
sets for safety and make them more
flexible so to make them more flexible
the two different things
incorporating high-performance control
within these reachable sets and then
using these ideas of if you're learning
more and more about the system over time
you're learning more and more about the
environment the disturbance functions
acting on the system so how would you
actually update the reachable sets over
time if you start to trust your model
that you're learning then maybe it's a
good idea to become less conservative
and update your reachable sets
all right so and this is implicit that
we're working on with NASA on forced
landing systems this is a shot of the
Berkeley campus and this presents kind
of a cost map if you were forced to land
a quadrotor right now on the Berkeley
campus you'd have you know pictures of
where the pathways are maybe buildings
you don't want to land on grass is good
but as you start to get close the
sensors pick
you know movement in these areas and
then they become regions that you don't
want to land on so you need to be able
to adapt and incorporate real time
information that you're gathering over
time all right so so really you know
what we talked about for reach ability
that was focusing on safety and
simplicity so safety from reach ability
simplicity from that hybrid model and
then learning dynamic behavior safely is
trying to address this data-driven or
ability to adapt to new information okay
so at Berkeley these days there's a big
effort in AI machine learning but not
only that it's it's deep learning so
that's what you know everybody in my
department that's working on robotics is
working on deep learning which means
that you're using a neural network for
learning and it's it's been used
amazingly beautifully in computer vision
and now there's more and more focus on
using it in robotics okay so we we
thought well just to motivate you know
data-driven incorporating data-driven
we just did this experiment in in the
past couple of months but this is our
little this is one of our littlest
quadrotors these little crazy flies and
we taught it to things we we taught it
to follow a sinusoidal track so that was
one neural net and then we also taught
it to ya' so to basically stay in place
and turn in circles which it turns out
is amazingly difficult surprisingly
difficult for the quadrotor to do it's
basically because you have to be very
careful about the frame of reference
it's Y all around and then we just asked
it to fly a trajectory which combine
those two things so basically now it's
tracking that trajectory while it's
turning in circles and and you know it
it didn't do as well as our lqr but
that's because we're control people
we're not deep learning people so we're
still learning how to do it properly but
we thought you could see a fairly good
result just by using like a this is a
two layer rectified linear unit norm net
okay so that's just my slide to say you
know there's there's some interesting
things in using neural nets for control
and we did this a long time I mean this
was done a long time ago
well not a long time ago but in I when I
was at Stanford I became good friends
with Bernie Woodrow and he did a lot of
this work in using AI are using neural
nets in control and but I think you know
just because of our ability to do these
computations much faster it's becoming
something that's possible now
yes and we're using the error between
acts between desired and actual to
update the neuron that no we're training
it we and that's a good idea we didn't
do that and we realized that we should
do quite a bit of that we're training it
by doing lots and lots of runs of that
figure-eight back and forth and back and
forth and that's the data that's one of
the reasons it's not doing as well as
the lqr because we just don't have
enough data to be able to get something
at such high fidelity yet so the we have
a desired trajectory it knows what its
desired trajectory is and we're
measuring the the distance between we're
measuring what it's a plot what control
inputs it's applying and the distance
between what it does and the actual
desired trajectory and those are the
inputs that that's what we're using as
training inputs so you go what you put a
lot of structure and control I guess we
have a lot of structure in the control
so it's um you know the the vehicle is
using a fairly good model of itself and
it's trying to learn a better model and
and so you know we're not doing any
safety nuts in this at all but we are
you know we're using a safety net which
is that the vehicle has a fairly good
model of itself to start out with by
watching experts play and then
right so our I guess our bootstrapping
is having some nominal model which we
know it you know is a is is going to get
the vehicle to track the trajectory
albeit not very well in fact you know
our performance is not only tracking the
trajectory well it's doing those figure
eights very quickly so the lqr as I keep
saying was able to do it much faster
than the neural net but it's because we
didn't have enough data to Train it okay
so we want to learn models of data but
now sorry we want to learn models from
data but we want to or learn better
models from data but we want to stay
safe while learning and so the first
thing we did we've we've taken a couple
of steps in this direction apart from
just that visual of the neural net
control is we decoupled those two
problems so if we have a nominal model
of our system with error bounds we don't
know what the error is that's what we'd
like to learn but we know what the
bounds are then we can compute a
reachable set based on the worst case
error and then that becomes a
conservative reachable set for the
system and then within that reachable
set we can perform you know whatever
learning scheme we want for high
performance so to visualize this this is
a this is our quadrotor in our lab we
took a nominal model of that with error
bounds and we computed a safe region of
operation inside this room so in this
case there's only one vehicle and we're
going to ask it to track a trajectory
where it's basically just performing a
step function up and down up and down in
altitude and safety means it doesn't
crash into the ceiling or the floor so
that's the so those safety envelope
represents you know when it has to start
slowing down so it doesn't crash into
the floor or the ceiling as it's going
up so we use the model to compute the
safety envelope and then we took the
model away from the vehicle and we asked
it to learn how to track that trajectory
so it's somewhat artificial in that we
used a model to compute compute the
envelope and then to demonstrate
learning we took the model away and the
learning that we're using is something
that's quite simple it's this policy
gradient sign derivative that Zico
Colter and Andrew Aang
designed so the first thing that happens
when you apply this scheme is the the
vehicle first drops because it doesn't
have a model of itself it doesn't have a
control but it doesn't crash because it
hits the boundary of the safe envelope
and then it just um it just sort of
hangs out near the bottom of that
envelope but it sort of bounces up and
down a bit and then bouncing up and down
it learns that if it applies a certain
thrust it goes up and it knows it has to
track this step trajectory which is
shown in blue and so after about a
minute using this scheme it does a
fairly good job of tracking that
trajectory okay so it's a bit of an
artificial example but it demonstrates
that you know you can teach it to track
a trajectory while it's some while it's
without crashing okay so it's not really
learning to fly from scratch because we
gave it the envelope that it had to stay
within and you know with the envelope
comes the control that has to apply on
the envelope from reach ability okay so
then we started to make it a little more
sophisticated and say well if we're
going to be learning these disturbance
functions or these errors over time we
could perhaps use that in updating the
envelopes and so we've been using
Gaussian process models for our
disturbance function so these are
Gaussian distributions over functions
and and so as we're as the vehicle is
flying we're basically getting data
points of you know if you apply this
control how it moved over the range of
either the state space itself or some
sub region of the state space that it
tends to fly in a lot and that allows
you those data points allow you to
update this disturbance function
okay so so then so the idea is then this
and this comes back to some of the very
earliest slides if you've got you know a
time invariant if you've got a
controlled invariant reachable set then
any super zero level set is also
controlled invariant so then as the
vehicles flying and it's always you know
it's it's getting data and then it's
asking whether or not this data matches
the model that it has of the
disturbances and if it if it's at any
point in the state space if it doesn't
match or if it doesn't match in a way
that indicates that it's not being
conservative enough it will scale back
and say okay I'm not going to I it's
it's it's doing I'm gathering data that
I'm not expecting so I'm going to expand
my reachable set using some super zero
level set and actually at that point
that was the first point at which it it
didn't validate its own model so it
chose the level set at that particular
point and uses that for it's it's
reachable set so this is a case of it
becoming more conservative and then as
it gets more and more data and and now
is the sort of the control question is
how do you then reconcile how much data
do you need to get before you trust your
model enough to be able to shrink these
sets this is this this initial
trajectory is it could be done in a
clever way right now we're just assuming
that it's some trajectory you're asking
the vehicle to fly so it may be that
trajectory you know just follow a
trajectory and and so it's something
that it's doing you know in general it
could be some other objective that the
vehicle wants to follow apart from
safety but if you knew that you were
trying to query something about safety
you would choose better trajectories for
this right now let's consider it some
arbitrary trajectory yeah and so over
time as you get more information you
could actually you know make this this
less conservative and so I'll skip the
safe learning I'll go actually to an
experiment to conclude with so that just
shows how we would do this but this is a
recent experiment we did with a single
with our quadrotor again there's a
similar experiment to the one I just
showed but we ran the experiment twice
and this is one experiment and that's
the second experiment in this case we're
using learning so we're using that
online validation and in this case we're
not and there's a fan here a fairly
strong fan but it's initially switched
off so the vehicles are slowly you know
going up into nothing nothing different
from what we did before but the fan when
it switched on provides a state
dependent disturbance so it basically
you know upsets the model that it has
about itself in this lower region of the
room okay so it's some it's it's flying
within its reachable set without the
disturbance it's got that safety
prevents it from going into the ground
but now in both cases the model is
inaccurate because the fan is switched
on in this case we don't have any
learning and in this case we do have
learning and it does what you would
expect so up here there's not really any
disturbance so the vehicles they're just
flying as normal but then as you see
them come down to where the fan is and
the fan really buffets them away so you
can see that so in this case there's no
online validation in this case we see no
learning in this case there is learning
and you see the well you don't see but
what's happening here is the safe set is
contracted it's basically doing that
thing where it says Maya the model that
I'm the model that I have of the vehicle
in this region is not accurate it's not
behaving as I expected the model to and
so it's simply you know it's quite
obvious what it would do but the
mathematics behind it is its contracting
the reachable set so that it's it's
allowing a reduced safe region for the
vehicle to fly in okay whereas this one
is just it's you know it's trying to
track that trajectory and it can't do it
there all right so um I'll skip the
local updates
and just conclude now okay so we've been
working on reachability analysis for
safety hybrid system representation for
simplicity so taking a complex system
and
breaking it into a number of modes and
using that to simplify the control of
the system and then really we've been
focusing in the last I would say four or
five years in incorporating learning
schemes into this and trying to think
about maybe more philosophically how to
blend learning with safety based control
some of the big questions so we alluded
to this in a safety critical scenario
how do you update these reachable sets
you know that's kind of I think it's
almost a philosophical question because
it it depends on when you trust your
model enough to be able to you know
update what you mean by safe and and a
lot of this is assuming that we're going
to have access to lots of data and we do
have access to lots of data as most of
the other talks in this workshop have
attested to I think one of the most
interesting questions which came up a
number of times this week is is the data
how do we what when we're looking at
self-driving cars and you know the
company is recording every driver that's
driving their car who really owns that
data or should own that data in the
future if it's a healthcare system you
know all these questions on platform
based systems that you know presumably
we're going to be using learning in a
much more integrative way in control and
then the the the reason I really got
into this is because I'm interested in
in autonomy where it's really human
centered automation and you know human
functionality with these systems is very
difficult to model and that's a prime
area where you could use learning very
effectively okay so that's that's one of
the areas I'm interested in we've worked
on apps to get you know information from
people's behaviors and autoland
functions with Boeing we have a set up
of capture the flag on campus here with
students and quadrotors team together
and then we've worked a lot with these
um you know air traffic data sets to try
to you know learn models of different
kinds of air traffic controllers okay so
with that I'd like to conclude and thank
the students who've worked so the
students in bold are the students who
are currently working with me about half
of those are working on these projects
and then students who've worked on these
problems but have recently graduated and
are at other places and then our funding
agencies thank you very much
bit of a campus is there any
relationship between reach ability and
approachability isn't like that close
approach ability theorem it's a
relationship between approachability
like black holes approachability theorem
so that's they go back to two-person
zero-sum game or the vector version of
that and you say like can I approach a
convex set on not only if this like
condition on the projection is the condo
set it seems like similar yeah III I
would say yes but I I'd have to learn
more about the concept of
approachability before before confirming
that but a lot of the examples in the
early examples in reach ability are from
you know two-person zero-sum games and
and and and you know trying to not only
characterize but but compute you know
before they're before using viscosity
solutions of PDEs they were actually
computing the characteristics of these
games and using those as the boundaries
of the reachable set so I imagine yes
but without going and studying it I and
I will that's a good lead any other
questions
when agent discovers that it's mater
this wrong it has to this one also has
to stop like discarding some of its
pride beliefs how and is there any way
to think about how much of its my
beliefs it needs to discard I presume it
doesn't start from scratch that that I
think is the the interesting question
too and and and maybe it's that's the
way to start approaching this this point
about how much of the original model are
you are you going to maintain so with
what we've done so far that part is
fairly obvious because we we have a
model and we model the disturbance as
some you know function that's affecting
our differential equations and so that's
the part that's unknown and we're either
getting a good model or not so we can
always you know go back to our old model
if we want to but in actual fact you
know when we're modeling things like you
know autonomous cars with where the the
big deal is to try to model effectively
what the environment is and the
environment are people crossing roads
and there's different kinds of people
and people who stop in the middle and
turn around and go back how to how to
really you know parse out those
components of the environment and turn
and and understand what what is what is
something that you you're sure about and
and what part you're uncertain about I
think that that's quite interesting and
that's really the direction to go so I
don't know you can't just fly flat you
have to try to get to the peaks and
valleys if you indicate what we do is we
we really separated into liveness and
safety so as long as it's satisfying the
safety constraints it will attempt to
minimize error on achieving the liveness
the liveness condition so in the
up-and-down case that's just that's just
coded as you know you want to stay as
close as possible to that trajectory in
eutm case those target sets are liveness
conditions so as long as you're you want
to get to the reach avoid set so that's
the set of states where you can reach
that's the liveness part while avoiding
the unsafe conditions so avoid as always
always has to be satisfied and it will
it will put it we'll put precedent of /
avoid like it will make avoid more
important than reach you could change
that but that's that's how we're
currently doing it for safety
okay thanks very much